so
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
come fly with me let's fly let's fly
away
if you can use some exotic booze there's
a bar in far bombay
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
or unless they see the sky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
violator previous corpus and freedom of
the press
abuser of
lincoln really were a tyrant mr woody
had your empty head impaled on a pike
which may achieve and cherish
adjust
and a lasting peace among ourselves
and with all nations
hello everyone uh welcome to the
academy's visiting artist film series
film aid edition for makeup and hair my
name is howard berger i'm a makeup
artist specializing in makeup effects
and
today i have the privilege of speaking
with the amazing and talented makeup
artist and uh overall fantastic person
lois burwell
um who has worked in this industry for
for a while and has done amazing things
um lois won an oscar academy award for
her work in braveheart she was dominated
for her work and pray uh saving private
ryan
she served as a branch governor
and she is truly a leader in the film
industry uh leader at the academy we all
love her dearly
and you know it takes more than just
being great at your job to be successful
you have to be
a great person
and this is something that lois is all
these things she really is so it's
wonderful to see you lois um
thank you for joining us this is going
to be fun we're going to learn all about
your your life and thoughts and all the
magic that you bring to the film
industry and to all of us in our
industry so how are you today
well after that introduction i'm blown
away i'm kind of disappointed by being
me now because this introduction is so
fantastic
um i'm all right today it's a rainy day
here and that's rather nice
it is yeah very nice very nice well
thank you for joining us uh you and i
have been friends for a very long time
uh we first met on green mile on the
green mile
and you taught me a lot about leadership
and and being uh
inclusive and working together as one
because sometimes being a makeup effects
person and
and being a makeup artist uh has the
perception of two different worlds but
it doesn't we work together and all
these years you and i have worked
together as colleagues and as very very
good friends
so what i want to do first is let's
start let's talk about the beginning
because this is always very interesting
because you have a very interesting uh
start in your career so you know you
were you were born in north london and
which is thousands of miles away from
hollywood california and i'm sure you
know at some point you were like this is
going to be impossible but you always
attack the impossible with possibilities
so
you know let's talk a little bit about
how it all started because also you
didn't you didn't begin the standard way
uk makeup and hair artists and stylists
begin which sometimes is through the
intense um structure of the bbc you you
went a different route and let's uh yeah
share with us a little bit about what
that was like how it all came came about
lois
well the thing is that i i was born into
a working class family where my
mother worked actually for the police as
a telephonist
and before that as a grosvenor house as
a telephonist
um and my father was an electrician a
household electrician so
there was never a thought of a career
that would be possible within makeup i
mean it wasn't something that now i
think it's much more
known and talked about especially with
social media and everything so there's
an advantage there but when i was
growing up it was something that was
beyond my dream or
comprehension and
i just i started really when i was at
dance school um at the evenings and
weekends just a local dance school
called the iris cordicott school of
dance
and when i was about five or six
that we were doing our classes doing a
dance of the dolls
and
everyone was turning up to rehearsal not
looking like a doll
so i started to interfere and basically
paint the other fellow students as dolls
and it just started from there and i
thought i really enjoyed this i liked
doing it i still didn't think that
there'd ever be a career um in it but i
would just tinker around at home and see
things that were in films that would
inspire me and think how would you do
that how can you do that and just work
it out with a very simple stage makeup
because that's what i had
and then when i got to a point where i
was about to leave school and i thought
well should i apply to the bbc but i
didn't want to work in television and i
know that sounds really i think back and
i think what a fall i was in many ways
but i just
i didn't want to do it i wanted to work
in film film was where my heart was film
is so exceptional because and i'm sure
that's why everyone's drawn to it
because you sit in that dream like state
you sit in the dark with strangers and
everything in your life stops in that
moment and you are taken to a different
world to different lives
having a different experience from your
own
life
so that's what i wanted to do i didn't
want to be confined within a box in the
living room
which is how i perceived television as
being um at that time
and so i started to write to fellow film
students
and offer my services
working on films for free
and that's basically
how i started
yeah oh go ahead i'm sorry no no no what
happened was um at the national film
school
you when you left you had a union card
so you graduated and were given more or
less access to work not the job itself
but access to work because the union was
really strict then in the uk and you
could not work without the union card
so and you and you had to have a union
card in order to work so it was a
catch-22 unless you had an in somewhere
where of course i obviously didn't
anyway what happened was the students
would be pleased with the work i did but
it wasn't just doing makeup i mean it
was everything it was everything from
editing
working on a steam back to taking over
sound
when the soundtrack went out for a
packet of cigarettes and we never saw
him again and you know i mean it was all
those kind of things so it was a real
i've got the frocks you've got the music
let's put on a show it was one of those
and
when they left some of them
got into doing what was then rock videos
you know
pop videos
because it was the beginning of that
then that's how old i am just so
everyone can work without on their
fingers now anyway so
um
and they asked me to work on them
and then of course you experimented and
it was a time especially with rock
videos of of doing elaborate or
extraordinary or different kind of you
know that punk rock through to glam rock
all those different looks
um so that's that's how i started and
then literally i was on a student film
coming back
from scotland and we stopped at a pub in
on the way down
obviously i was of a legal age to have
an alcoholic beverage at that time
anyway so we stopped at the pub
and
it was a very it was the filmmakers pub
in glasgow so
everyone knew everyone else
and two chaps came in and one i was
talking to
we just struck up a conversation about
filmmaking in general
and i never spoke to his friend
and then a year later i get a phone call
from a lovely production manager called
paddy hixson who's no longer with us
um
but was a lovely woman anyway so she
telephoned me and she said lois are you
interested in doing bill forsyth's film
gregory's girl
and i said i don't know bill
and she said well he knows you
because you were talking to his friend
mike who happened to be mike radford
um
in the halt on your way back from
brian's film and i said
really i mean i had no
i had no recollection
but he'd obviously seen the work and and
thought that it would be good to work
with me
so that's how i started and and that
makes it sound like you you step out the
door and that's it you're an instant
makeup artist the one thing i really
want to inspire everyone
is that
a certain amount of it is determination
but it's also self-determination in
you constantly work to push the envelope
i mean i still want to be a good makeup
artist i still look forward to being a
good makeup artist i don't believe
a hundred percent that i am right now
because i can always improve you know
you can't rest on your laurels is what
i'm saying
so
when i when i started
it it was just the beginning
and i had no idea of where anything
would go and and or where it would lead
to it wasn't a thought of right now i'm
going to hollywood i mean
that's
that has actually has never been a part
of my agenda it's always been
this job or that interesting film
this collaboration
this feels right and i think to a
certain degree
if there's something i've learned it's
that if something feels wrong
then it's better if you can not do it
i agree yeah i always i always feel it's
i never regret saying no but i regret
saying yes
so
yeah did you were your parents
supportive
they well they were supportive in that
they i mean yes they were supportive in
that yes have a go at that but they
didn't believe it could be
you know a career they they because it
was it was beyond their comprehension in
fact there's a rather amusing story i
did a film very early on in my career
with glenn jackson called gyro city
and glenn jackson's a wonderful actress
and my mom of course absolutely adored
her in elizabeth r which was a
television program that she was
exceptional in and everyone throughout
the country was just you know enamored
with her and quite rightly so
um
but i i was working on the film and mom
said to me you know
when when you're there doing the makeup
do you actually touch her
i couldn't believe it
it's funny though yeah it's it's it's uh
but it is important to have you know
like you were saying it you need to
believe in yourself but it certainly
helps when you have a family and parents
too that help you know support you and
and let you go down this journey you
know so it's it's uh it's there's a lot
to it um
mind you yes i don't know about that
because there was always that thing
about you must do something so you have
a proper job
well of course yeah i mean even i think
now even after all these decades people
still like so what do you still do that
you still make monsters i'm like yeah
yeah yeah i do it's been 40 years i
think i'm probably going to stick with
it so yeah exactly absolutely um you
know in our in our industry we do a lot
of collaborating so i mean we have to we
can't just be an island um
and
there's going to talk a little bit about
braveheart since that's the film that
you you won your academy award for but
on that film you met your husband john
paul who was the cinematographer amazing
cinematographer great great brilliant
artist
who mel gibson says is the greatest
cinematographer alive so which is true
but you know it's interesting because
you've done a couple movies with john so
what's that collaboration and working
relationship with because he's obviously
your husband you're his wife but you
have to feel confident to put something
in front of the camera that you feel
good that you know he's looking at it
through his view viewfinder but also you
have to trust him to
present it properly you know in the way
you see it too so let's as far as
collaboration goes let's start there
let's talk about the collaboration
between the cinematographer and the
makeup artist
well that's how we met i mean
i i looked back at it and it was very
clear i mean it wasn't it wasn't like
going on a date or or a romantic
encounter
um
that isn't what it was about what it was
about is when you start on a film you
know obviously i was quite nervous and
you want to do a good job and you want
you know to to
get the character exactly right and all
those things
and when i first met john actually i
thought he was the operator because he
was operating the camera and it was a
makeup test
and he looked up from behind the camera
and he's kind of scowled at me kind of
frowned and of course i thought he
looked funky i don't like the look of
him
but actually what it was is that he
didn't have his glasses on so he was
squinting to try and get me in focus
[Laughter]
but literally how we came together was
that i mean there wasn't time to chat on
the film set it wasn't like we were
talking to each other about anything
other than the work
so it was always work based and we'd go
to rushes every night so we'd see
dailies every night and in the beginning
obviously everyone was really
enthusiastic and there'd be like 35
people
going or 40 people going to dailies to
see their work and then by the end of
week two when the hours are long and the
weather was really inclement
but by the end of the second week there
were like four of us so
and it was always myself and john
so
we would discuss i mean i remember one
thing was that obviously mel was meant
to be in in the script it had him
described wallace as william wallace as
being described as in his early 20s well
mel was in his early 40s
and he was directing producing as well
as starring in the film so he wasn't
getting a lot of sleep
so instead of looking all refreshed and
you know heroic he was looking rather
wrinkly and tired to be perfectly honest
and john said to me can you do something
to make me
make him look you know more youthful and
i said well i i i'm doing the best you
know and but poor soul you know there's
only x amount you can do
and
in fact it was john's birthday when we
first started shooting
and
i had found an empty packet
of cigarettes and i put
gaffer tape round them and wrote on them
as a little present
instant wrinkles guaranteed to annoy
hollywood tested by john toll and gave
them to him
and
i suppose that's how
we can actually see each other as people
rather than as
film colleagues
but it was always about the work so when
i've worked with him on other things i
mean i know to trust him because we've
trodden that path and in actual fact
we've worked on films when we did
captain corelli's mandolin and the two
lead actors not penelope cruz but two
others had no idea that we were a
married couple
none
until about four or five weeks into the
shoot because there was nothing on the
when we were at work that would tell
anyone that
right which is the way to do it yeah you
don't want to get it so yeah
do you feel that working no you know
being married to john and working with
him that's helped you with other
cinematographers like
in terms of what you know
uh you know what what you what the
cinematographer expects you know i know
you you hold yourself at very high re
you know
level you know you're very very specific
about things and you you always want to
make sure it's brilliant so but um yeah
it must be you're used to john and then
you go to set with another dp and you
know yeah i mean but but that can be
that can be a double-edged sword i'm
going to be perfectly honest because the
people that no i mean most people don't
know when i go to work who i'm married
to i mean i was working with steven
spielberg we weren't married john and i
at the time but we were dating and it
was almost the penultimate day of saving
private ryan before stephen knew that i
was with or janish knew that i was with
john
so you know there's that but
when you
you know sometimes it's oh she thinks
she knows because she's married to i
mean i remember an a.d
who was married to a makeup artist who
used to come in and give notes on how to
make up
you know people in the background or
small characters and i said excuse me
where is this coming from
is this from the director are you
passing on a note from the director you
said no i just think it's a good idea
and i said look you're married to a
makeup artist you're not a makeup artist
and you're not the head of department go
away
[Laughter]
so
i understand and i don't want ever to be
that person
but
obviously you have to work
collaboratively i mean whenever i start
work on a film
the port of call is the script to read
the script and to read it as if you are
sitting in the cinema watching it that's
the way i do it and then i do a
breakdown a technical breakdown of the
script which i call the makeup script so
it's you know you know how i mean a day
passes
are they tired have they got red eyes is
it hot out is it cold out
have they had a wash you know all those
questions you ask yourself about every
single character
and
so having done that then met with the
director and seeing where our ideas
merge or if we can work together because
there's no point trying to be the ugly
sister
putting you cramming your foot in
cinderella's shoe there is no point
you're never going to get anywhere
so or it won't be
fulfilling and then
you let the film down there's nothing to
say you're always the right person
for the job you know i think that's
important to recognize anyway so
yeah so after that having met the
director then the next port of call is
production design because i want to see
the overall vision that what they're
working on and then it's the
cinematographer
you know before costume before meeting
the actor it has to be the
cinematographer
got it yeah no i agree i agree there's
definitely that success the succession
of it all
um
yeah it's it is it's a giant
collaborative effort you know and even
even you know here in the united states
there's a delineation between hair and
makeup but in but overseas there's not
you know for the most part it's it's
it's one of the same so
um and yeah you need to work with a
you know a great hair stylist designer
who you feel good about as well because
it all comes together i mean it all
there's so much that
has to be taken into account and then
you have the actor yeah no exactly you
know so yeah it's like you feel where
you or me i mean it it's it's a big
jigsaw puzzle that's how i always think
yeah it is and it is you're just a
little piece of that jigsaw puzzle but
sometimes you can be the most important
piece you know oh absolutely so and i
think i think that's true of everyone
and and you don't i mean the other
extraordinary thing i don't know about
you how but i've found over the years
that
there's a kind of a confusion between
being a colleague
and being a friend
and they're not necessarily the same
thing people bandy around the time oh my
friend this my friend
no your colleagues and sometimes
you can be collegial and work
exceptionally well with someone but not
particularly warm to them
in any other context other than
being at work and i think starting out
that can be very confusing
when you're you know brand new
yeah
and i think it can be very disappointing
too because
you know
in any artistic realm you you have to be
prepared to take risks and to take risks
you have to be prepared to fail
and to
take the wrong the wrong choice
of a makeup or take the wrong choice of
a job even
but it's all part of a learning curve
including
that and i'm sure it's been said to you
i know it's been said to me
i'm going to have you work with me on
all of my films oh yeah
and then you never see that person again
you know and then the surprise can be
that the person that you've never you
know that you were just being
regular collegial
decent to
is the runner who becomes the studio
head
or
the producer you know so
i think it i think that
working collaboratively with anyone no
matter how talented they are or not
i think you have to
recognize the humanity in everyone
and embrace it and make it a part of
your ethic of work
only because
if you
i'm trying to think how to say this to
students hopefully some of whom are
going to be incredibly successful makeup
artists and hair stylists and
i think
you can't spend 40 years i mean i've
been doing it for more than 40 years as
you have had
and you can't spend 40 years being
someone else
you can only
because it's disrespectful i think to
your own life and it's confusing
to your growth
it's very important that you are
truthful to yourself
as well as to others
when asked
and i think
and i could be wrong but i think that's
the best recipe
for a successful life and a successful
career to be perfectly frank
no i agree i think that's great advice
because sometimes i think we get you
know caught up in the inertia of it all
and it's just you focus just on this and
it's it's bigger than that and and your
department the film is bigger life is
bigger than just your department
sometimes we just focus on like what's
got to be this got to be this
you know it's also i think what you were
saying is
i find it's it's much easier to be nice
to everybody than not and and you're
right you don't know like i i work with
a pa in the 80s and he's a big director
now you know and i was always nice to
him he hasn't hired me but that's okay
but nonetheless you know but but you
know i watch people who
in our industry who sometimes aren't
very nice and and it's it's not you know
you're going to be you're going to be
remembered for how you made people feel
you know
and and what and what they take away
from the experience and and it's very
important to treat everybody with
respect um that's a very good bit of
advice lois it's actually the best you
know it's better than like oh learn how
to do browser learn how to do this it's
like just be a really good person you
know it makes a world of difference um
and obviously you know you you've worked
with uh
people uh time and time again who value
you on all levels and and as a person as
as an artist and as a uh
a contributor and a team member because
that's really what you are you're not
someone who just comes and you do the
job and then you sit in a chair all day
long and look at a magazine you you are
a team member and you're part of the
creative team and that's something that
we're we really try to push you know
you're not a vendor
um you obviously have worked uh
uh quite a bit with steven spielberg and
um
on movies like lincoln and ready player
one and warhorse and of course we talked
about saving private ryan
and he he obviously values you um
tremendously and and would you just
share a little bit about what it's like
working with him you know uh because
he's my one of my all-time favorite film
directors in the world and
um
and i just think it's wonderful that you
get to work with him all the time so
talk a little bit about that if you
would well i think it's right i think
he's one of the biggest joys of my
career to be honest i mean i i i have
other personal joys or little things
that i like about certain things but
that that re working with stephen is
fabulous and in fact you know i i was a
huge stephen fan i mean massive
and
went in you know trampling the queen's
crisp packets and and popcorn boxes
after the royal performance you know to
be the first in there to see close
encounters
um
when i was a teenager and it was just
i mean
i didn't ever think that i'd be working
with him and i tell you the first the
first job that
we worked together well i say we worked
together we didn't work together at all
i was you know very i was doing the
crowd um on indiana jones and the temple
of doom i was called by the makeup
artist tom smith
and he said would you come and do days
because someone
another colleague had
to go and do pickups on the bond film
and i said oh on the stephen spielberg
film oh i don't think i can and because
my first thing was oh no i'm not good
enough and
he said just get your kit and get here
at five tomorrow morning i mean it was
just like
okay fine
turn up and it was just
i i'll share i'll share a story i mean i
don't know
it's not something that i broadcast but
i i do remember that it was in the days
when there wasn't so much security
so i turned up at elstree studios in
north london and
i couldn't drive at the tanks i couldn't
afford a car so
i'd ordered a mini cab which meant that
for the journey it probably cost me half
my day's paying
to get there and back yeah
anyway
because it was before the train started
otherwise i'd gone on the train and the
bus anyway so um
so it's not all glam
i suppose that's the other way of saying
it's a contrast isn't it
and
i knew i was shooting on the makeup room
i got this so early i got there about i
don't know quarter past four because i
was keen and nervous
that the makeup block was locked up so
there was nowhere to go so i'm wondering
and i can see just a work light on h
stage which was where the temple of doom
was actually constructed
so i just walked through the door walked
through the stage door and walked onto
the set
and i walked round
and the feeling inside me i mean it
makes my eyes water now um
because it was it was such an emotional
feeling
of
wonder and magic and something so
special
and i was walking through the tunnel and
there were two work lights at either end
just so there there's a dark bit in the
middle and then two paws of light so
very filmic anyway
and as i was walking through
someone was walking in the opposite
direction
and i stopped in the pool of light and
they stopped in the pool of life and it
was stephen
so it was a very magical thing and he'd
obviously gone to the stage i mean i
don't think he even remembers it but
he'd gone to the stage to look at the
set to work out what it was he was going
to do that day she's always prepared
i have never known him not be prepared
in the lunch time he's in the editing
room
editing he edits as he goes he's there
at the makeup call editing before the
days to start the day's shooting
he
is a genius in that he gets he has a
plan he has a vision in his head and you
are doing it in that next moment but if
something doesn't work like the gimbal
on the landing craft the first day
shooting on the beach and saving private
rhyme the gimbal wasn't working so he
just turned around and changed the shot
changed what he was going to do and can
be inventive in that way
he can think faster than
anyone else i know of on a film set and
come up with something else
and you have to you have to work to keep
up with that and
when you present an idea and he's really
open to
ideas and you don't want to get in the
way and he doesn't really like makeup
here faffing around on the set that's
how he sees it and he wants the work
done but somehow it's got to be
invisibly done by fairies
rather than practically gluing a beard
on i mean the amount of times i mean in
the beginning i was just terrified
because it would be make up head get out
you know that's true yeah yeah yeah and
excuse me and
you know i i'd be shaking in my shoes
but then i just learned that you just
stuck and dived so i just
dip out a vision and then when you'd
turn around and look in the opposite
direction i'll just pop up again
you just you and you learn to do things
really quickly but you give him ideas
and he builds on it so it's like be
careful what you wish for you come up
with a good idea and then suddenly
instead of it being you know a little
hill it's now mount everest and you have
to climb it because you started that
chain of thought but the one thing i
will tell you is that you are a better
technician an artist
at the end of that film than you were on
day one
yeah and the thing i love about stephen
best of all i mean he's wonderful with
old people and children he really is i
mean he's incredibly patient and
terribly kind actually
um
but when something goes right on that
set
and you've got the take even if it's
been billy goat gruff before then and
it's been slightly you know kind of
impatient and it's all been a bit on the
set but stressful and everything but you
get that shot and it's like yes yes
we've got it and he's like a
nine-year-old
or the first day on the first film he's
ever directed and that's
it's wonderful to behold yeah
you know i and and to be a part of that
magic even in a small way
is fabulous
well i mean he he truly loves film and
that's something else like
you know i'm always surprised when we
have colleagues and and uh from any
department and they go i'm not really
into watching i'm not a big movie fan or
watch movies i'm like what are you doing
this for yeah you know that's the whole
thing is about loving movies like you
know i know you and i are constantly
texting each other like okay i watched
five movies tonight what did you watch
and uh you know we're movie fanatics
we're cinephiles and i know he is too
and when you when you talk about him
being resourceful i mean you know look
at jaws he saved that entire movie the
shark didn't work so hey let's just do
pov so
and in our in our world in every world
is it's
i always feel like it's the work that we
do is we know how to do it but it's the
problem solving and they have to be huge
problem solvers you know yeah huge and
that and that actually that's the key to
it that's that i think that's the
biggest key
what do you do most of the day
once you've made them up isn't that it
well of course that's never it because
it's like the fourth bridge you paint
one end and then by the time you've got
to the end you've got to start all over
again i mean that's yeah that's the
nature of makeup but
the biggest job is problem solving and
and it's coming up with something and it
can be i remember on catch me if you can
so there's a little boy in there in the
hospital then it's when um
uh abanavi
was pretending to be a doctor in the
hospital so there's a little boy and
he's got a broken knee there's he's
broken his knee about had some kind of
accident anyway some kind of trauma
and he said it in the script so i said
are we going to see this do we need a
prosthetic piece
no we're never going to see it
see it
so then
janice who
is a diamond i just i adore yanish as a
cinematographer he's fabulous and he's a
really decent person anyway
he said to me
you know we're starting the shot on the
kid's knee
went
what you know so
what you're gonna do you can't you can't
let the set wait you don't have a
prosthetic broken knee so i had to come
up with something so what i did was i
cut up a makeup sponge put wax around it
bled it onto the kid's knee dressed it
with blood and that's what you're
looking at in a massive close-up
you know not not something elaborately
made i mean you
i i once had to do a lookalike for
prince charles
on a film that had no money at all i
mean it was too bob and a toffee apple
it was it was really
you know you were trying to separate the
kleenex into layers to save money
it was one of those um
and his ears wouldn't be and i didn't
have i didn't have the wear with all the
lab or anything else
to
give the push that the ears actually
needed so yet again i cut up this is
true
i cut up a makeup sponge and glued it
the wedge part
so that his ears and it was actually
quite soft and didn't hurt but it pushed
the ears forward
there was a magazine i don't know if
it's available globally or i don't even
know if it's still in existence to be
perfectly on it's called hello magazine
and they used to do visits on sets and
bits and bobs and it was mainly
celebrity gossip i mean you know
but sometimes a big wedding or you know
that kind of thing anyway
something that people flipped through in
the hairdressers
so
they came to interview and i'm standing
on the set and the producer said of
course you have to go through the makeup
trailer
and
you know maybe you would want to take
some photographs of our makeup artist
lois applying prince charles prosthetics
[Laughter]
oh gosh yes and the whole of my life
flashed before my eyes and i thought oh
my god that's it i can't basically have
anyone take a photograph of cutting up a
makeup sponge and throwing it on back
yeah well but that's part of what we do
like literally things
you know you plan and plan and uh
production changes their mind and
directors change their minds as it's
their prerogative and it's our job to
like okay uh all right i know what we're
going to do like you and i both have the
privilege of working with danny streep
who is a great great makeup artist he's
passed on but i think of him every
single day and he really
um
pushed the push the the belief and i do
agree with him that and this is this is
not ego driven but we are the most
important people on set because we he
would always say this like we're the
most important people we have to figure
out we start the actors day we end the
day they come in looking terrible we fix
it there's a problem over here we fix it
we can do anything and i really do
believe that because you know sometimes
as
as you have done
our job which we don't anticipate goes
into other departments and we have to
help other departments figure out like i
work a lot with costume i'm like okay
well oh i have an idea we can do that i
know how to get
you know how to make some costume look
all bloody without using blood so give
me the costume and i'll bring it back
i'll be fine but let's talk a little bit
about actors um because like i just said
we start the day we start the actor's
day and we end the day and we always
want to make sure that they're they feel
safe
and and um secure and confident so
because again we you know we've worked
with thousands and thousands of actors
and we don't have to be specific about
actors specific actors but but in the
sense of like what are you what how how
do you go about you're going to do a
film and you have an actor and let's see
an a-list actor comes in and he's going
to be in your chair what would your how
would you
go about like having him feel
comfortable and confident and and
trusting you because we really you know
it's
we we do x amount
you know as part of our job and then the
actor goes and does the rest you know
but ultimately it's their face on that
40-foot screen you know that's right
but you know you have to
i think that i mean well the first thing
i always do is that if it's obviously a
known actor i will bone up on their
filmography
and i will want to see them either over
the years or
them on a screen and in different
environments playing different roles so
that i actually have a working knowledge
inside my mind of
their face
with different expressions
and
playing different roles so i can i can
see the
i suppose the canvas
i get to know the canvas that you're
actually
working with
um
as best i can
right i i don't i
it's a it's a difficult question to
answer because
i literally it goes back to
another answer to be honest i think i'm
just myself and
what i don't do is i don't do what i
call fluff and fold
i think that there's a difference
between especially
as a makeup artist i think
it can be seen as being
a handmade
it can be
and that isn't something or a role that
i would ever wish
anyone to be in or would encourage them
in order to
make an actor feel better or more
special
do you know what i mean there's you have
to find the boundary of that
um but obviously you want to be kind and
if someone has a problem with something
then you know they've got spots or
whatever it happens to be you know a
blemish um and it worries them then you
you're considerate and
you solve the problem and make them feel
better about it of course but you don't
lie i think that's the most important
thing never be untruthful if you can't
actually speak the truth say
nothing i think that that's that's a
rule of thumb and
i don't talk about myself
whenever i
meet an actor i talk about the work as
if the work is something
that
is there
that unites both of us and that's our
meeting point
it's not
my personality or their personality it's
the work and that's i think how you
create confidence and an ability to work
with each other
there was an actor who shall remain
nameless who
was truthful enough actually although it
took a little bit of work to say
i really do not want and i would not
have taken this role if i thought that i
had to have makeup
i would not have taken this
role
and
said i'm so terribly sorry but the thing
is that we are both in service of this
film
and
we are going to need you to be in this
makeup
in order to give the director his vision
and in fact fulfill the remit
for from both of us
to tell the story of this film through
your character
and
what we need to
do is find a place
where
you are not hampered in your performance
by the consciousness or the physicality
of the makeup
and i can still for fulfill the remit
of the director's vision and indeed the
script
so we have to find
where we can dovetail and where we can
meet and i could have been replaced
because they're not going to replace the
actor they're going to replace the
makeup artist
but it's very important to be
truthful and that's not ego driven it's
just factual
yeah no it's true
it's true and and i think that's smart
like that's a good another great uh
piece of advice is don't make it about
yourself
you know you're you're there and there
it is important to keep a line in the
sand between personal and business you
know
and i think sometimes that gets a little
mixed up and you put you compromise the
actor too because then the actor feels
like there may be a little
misinterpretation of a personal
relationship just a friendship but you
don't want to go there you're there to
do a job and do the best job and and
they are too they're not there to be
your best friend if you want a best
friend get a dog
and that'll be great or a cat
or a cat pillow like you have behind
you but uh yeah that's a very important
thing because i think also people that
are up and coming in the industry and in
our world
sometimes get that confused like you
know try to dig in and and become
friends and and that's not what you're
there for no that and that can blow up
so easily i mean on both sides as well
and and that's not right because the
thing is
there's there's the give and take and
there has to be a point even if you've
worked and i've been privileged enough
to work with you know some wonderful
actors on numerous films and be
requested by them and
it's always a surprise it's never an
expectation i mean i always you know
always thrilled to be asked for it's
lovely um and
but there comes a point where
you have to say
you know what i know you want this
but this is not this is not in your
service in the end
you need to look like x not y
because
i think you'll find it so you have to be
able to have that ground of professional
relationship to negotiate
it can't be oh it's lois again doing it
i mean
they have thought that
i mean i remember once
i there was an actor in my chair and
obviously we we we've worked together
you know quite a bit
and
it was one of those days where you know
we're we're i mean gone now obviously
with kobe the one good thing about covet
is there's no food in the trailer thank
god
because that's nothing more irritating
than that but it was one of those days
where we're on the phone someone's
having a conversation standing you know
in the doorway of the trailer
uh
we're on the phone someone's standing in
or popping in and out with different
updates so it's constantly you know
moving and then
there's chewing gum
and then the headset went in and all i
did was i went
because
i've got 10 minutes to do this i'm going
to throw myself out the window if i did
i mean it was just
you know i was kind of up to here and
the the air bubbles came out
the chewing stopped and it and the and
the actor said
what really upset you was it someone
coming in out
the
chewing of the gum
phone calls knowing all of it
[Laughter]
that's being a person you know yeah and
yeah
yeah we all have our frailties and
yeah
yeah and hopefully at the end of the day
you know you you do a great job and the
actor's happy and and like you said
every job i end i can be doing a film
with an actor or films with an actor
multiple times i never expect a phone
call i just go thank you so much for the
opportunity it was great
and you know best of luck but and then
if they call you're like wow that's
really nice it's a nice surprise it's
just part of the gravy you know but
never ever
feel like oh yeah i'm going to be doing
this guy forever that's that doesn't
exist it will never exist so those of
you that are getting into the industry
please remember that it's just
you're there to do the job do the best
job you can be super friendly to
everybody and all that good stuff um i
have a question a technical question
actually um now that now that filmmaking
has changed so much now that we're not
dealing so much with film there are some
filmmakers that still use film but
mostly digital have you found that it's
um have you come over the process where
you're dealing with um
being able to work with different skin
tones because also our films are getting
more diverse which is great more you
know our actors are far more diverse
it's not what we we're used to we're
really opening up the gates and and
everybody is inclusive in filmmaking now
and do you have do you have you had to
uh learn more about things like this or
how do you approach it now with in this
world to be perfectly honest i think
that everything especially with makeup
comes down to the to the color wheel i
mean that's
down to you have to know what the color
really is and tones within that so
the
when i was first starting out um
you know you had to be able to make up
everyone to look
in all different ways right um for
example you know they're stumped stump
men um who were little there was a
little person who
i work with regularly actually for a
whole called shearing
kieran shaw yeah
a great
stuntman and coordinator and a fabulous
person well i turned kieran into
everything from you know a green fairy
in legend through to
um a washer woman
for a perspective double
to
an edwardian child
a caucasian
edwardian child through to
um well
i'm trying to think the last time i mean
he's been a pixie a goblin he's been
every shade of skin tone you can imagine
so
i don't think that that has changed
that's that's that they're the arrows
that are in our quiver
you know of maker so
i do think what's happened and i'm quite
relieved about it actually is that
it's less
i think makeup is more subtle
yes
and i like that i've always
enjoyed and want to use whenever is
possible obviously raw skin even in film
days um before digital i like raw skin i
like how it looks i think it makes
people just
somehow subliminally you recognize that
it's another person not a made-up person
in front of you
so
for all those reasons i've always been a
fan of that so it hasn't really affected
me that much i think it might have
affected some of my colleagues more
that are more inclined to foundation
being their go-to
right
i mean i i like to do things like paint
on freckles you know i've always liked
to do that to create characters those
sorts of things so
yeah i know that's great and that's the
detail yeah i agree with you i i think
less is more
especially on men it's it's really just
taking being observant knowing your
color wheel that knowing what skin looks
like i feel like if you if you know
those things you're good to go with
everything exactly and uh yeah and just
pay attention when you're on set look at
the monitor maybe look through the lens
well don't yeah
but trust your eye i mean that's the
thing i i think now of everything to be
perfectly honest
i think that you can technically
teach people how to do things you can
always
teach people how to do things practical
tasks this is how you block a wig this
is how you block a beard except that's
really not taught yeah yeah but what you
can't teach anyone and i've never known
it be able to be taught is to have an
eye
the eye for either observation
or recreation of something that
that ability to look at something and
see
you know like the
um
native peoples when they did
sculptures from a stone that the the
sculpture is already in existence within
the stone you just take away the debris
to reveal what was already there
that
and that in our job
is the difference between
night and day
if someone has that ability that you
look at a face and you don't see the
face in front of you you see
who and what that face can become you've
been a member of the academy of motion
picture arts and science for quite a
while what what does that mean to you
what does it mean to you to be a member
do you remember being invited in to the
academy and what that felt like well
well there are three things actually
that all come together because one leads
to the other
um
and i'm going to tell you
a little story if i may if there's time
for it so yes
we when i was
uh an officer
and on the board of the academy
they were doing a retrospective of
greece
and
i was there and you know there are lots
of other people as well but there was
john travolta and olivia newton john
there they were
like feet in front of me now when i was
so i suppose a late teenager i can't
remember how old i was but
i went to see greece in the odeon
muswell hill because i lived in north
london with my friend
marina
and
we came out of that and danced our way
to the bus to go home
and as i sat in the goldwing which is
the most magnificent cinema to me
it's the mecca of cinemas
um
in the row in front of me
was olivia newton john
and john travolta
and as the curtain opened
and you saw the beginning of the film
i suddenly had this feeling of the past
and the present
colliding
that young woman
had no idea that she would
one day have her bottom part in the gold
wing
be an academy
member
and work in hollywood it was just it was
it was somehow
like going to the moon you know
something that was unbelievable which of
course now we can do if you've got
enough money you can pay to go but you
know it's
it was that so
in a way it's always been
mystical to me and and somehow
treasured and
beyond
comprehension in a way rather like
saying you know
i i have an academy award
that that alone is so rare it's such a
rarity and
it's somehow almost nothing to do with
me it's it's an external
factor but i tell you what
is
really special i feel is to be in
service
i love to be in service yes
i like to be in service of something
bigger than me
i like that about filmmaking because
it's the project that's bigger than you
i like it about the academy because
it's about the other
364 days of the year as well as
the academy awards
so
that i think it's a privilege i think
it's something you need to take you know
i take terribly seriously and also
light-heartedly i mean i
i always think that one of the most
important things not that i could use it
now because of the kobe protocols but
the most one of the most important
things i've always had in my kit
on any film i've ever done is what i
call the attitude adjuster
and the attitude adjuster is a clown's
red nose
[Laughter]
i like that
and it's
important because you take things
seriously and lightly at the same time
that's true well lois this has been
wonderful thank you so much for your
time and your your words of wisdom and i
hope that everyone watching this walks
away with
a handful of great advice and and
encouragement you know because
everything is possible you know we like
you said about olivia newton john we
never you know when we were younger we
never had any thought we'd be here today
like be it really be in the industry or
you know be where we are or be in the
academy or
or all of it just you know being in the
being in the film industry is is a
privilege so lois once again wonderful i
love speaking with you hey everyone
thank you for participating in the
academy's visiting artists film series
film aid edition for makeup and hair
hope you enjoyed it thank you